ein routine polizeieinsatz dort wer
außer kontrolle gerät
rassismus skandal bei der berliner
polizei
die beamten suchen die wohnung einer
syrischen familie auf sollen einen
haftbefehl wegen mehrfachen
schwarzfahrens gegen einen 30-jährigen
mann vollstrecken zudem eine sogenannte
gefährderansprache zur verhütung einer
straftat gegen seine 28-jährige frau
durchführen weil sich der verdächtige
offenbar wert werfen ihnen die beamten
zu boden legen ihm handschellen an das
alles vor den augen seiner 28-jährigen
frau und den gemeinsamen kindern als die
ehefrau einschreitende folgen
rassistische äußerungen des beamten
die situation so eskaliert im
hintergrund deutlich zu hören die
schreie des ehemanns
die drohungen des polizeibeamten gehen
weiter
durch die zahlung von 750 euro für das
wiederholte schwarzfahren sahen die
polizisten von einer verhaftung
ableiteten jedoch ein
ermittlungsverfahren wegen widerstands
tätlichen angriffs und versuchter
gefangenenbefreiung durch die ehefrau
ein kurze zeit später erstattete das
syrische paar selbst anzeige wegen
körperverletzung zeigen der polizei zu
dem das video des rassistischen
übergriffs mit folgen denn inzwischen
ermittelt der staatsschutz schreibt die
polizei berlin auf twitter unser
staatsschutz ermittelt wegen
fremdenfeindlicher beleidigung eines
kollegen gegenüber einer frau bei einem
einsatz der sie und ihren mann betraf
das paar erstattete gemeinsamen anzeige
bei einem polizeiabschnitt und zeigte
ein video der tat es ist ein skandal der
konsequenzen hat wir stehen gegen
jegliche form diskriminierenden und
menschenverachtenden verhaltens gegen
den kollegen wird strafrechtlich
ermittelt er wurde unmittelbar in den
innendienst versetzt weitere
dienstrechtliche konsequenzen folgen
konsequenzen damit solch abscheuliche
aussagen durch einen polizeibeamten nie
mehr vorkommen
sprechen wir mit unserem polizeireporter
matthias becker der selbst früher
polizist war matthias rassismus bei der
polizei ist das ein problem
nein also wir sind uns alle einig
rechtsradikalismus
hat in einer behörde die für die
verfassung zuständig ist zum schutz des
grundgesetzes der bundesrepublik nichts
zu tun und muss sofort entfernt werden
aber wir müssen eines wissen oder das
was ich jetzt hier sehen ist ist es die
tiefe gesinnung eines beamten
rassistisch zu sein oder
schlichtweg einfach in der situation
überfordert mit der mentalität der ja
der betroffenen ihr deal aus syrien
kommen und da hat da überreagiert wir
dürfen nicht sofort mit der rassismus
keule draufschlagen und vorteil wie
hätte der beamte sich verhalten sollen
wenn es nach lehrbuch gegangen wäre
naja wir sehen auch dass da ein also
dass der mann der familienvater vor den
augen mindestens eines kindes in
handschellen ich sag mal auf dem boden
gefesselt
sitzt und noch ein glas wasser gereicht
was ist natürlich ehrverletzend und das
ist natürlich höchst problematisch auch
für die familie das dem vater das vor
den augen des kindes so
geschehen ist und man darf auch nicht
vergessen das dann natürlich zur
gesichtswahrung gerade der mentalität
anderer mitbürger aus anderen
kulturkreisen besondere emotionen
hochschlagen das hätte der beamte wissen
können und wir müssen auch immer den
einsatz anlass sehen er ist ja lediglich
nur schwarzfahren wir reden ja nicht von
einer einer staatsgefährdenden straftat
verdächtig sondern wirklich schwarz
wenn wir die bilder jetzt gerade sehen
er wird heruntergedrückt mit dem kopf
runter gehalten und logischer weise
eskaliert dann die situation
die frau ruft und schreibt dann auch wie
kann das sein dass ein polizeibeamter
auch wenn er unter stress steht auch
wenn er immer wieder in situationen
gerät wo er vielleicht nicht respektiert
und geachtet wird trotzdem so die
kontrolle dann verliert müsste nicht
gerade der ausgebildete polizisten dabei
herrschen können oder ist das
ausbildungsniveau einfach gesunken
nein das ausbildungsniveau ist schon
sehr sehr gut also über einsatzlehre
taktik psychologie der polizei warnte
durchläuft egal ob mittlerer dienst oder
oder gehobener dienst alle stationen die
eigentlich ihnen darauf vorbereiten was
da passieren kann aber was passiert
tagtäglich arten zwölf stunden dienst er
ist permanent
anfeindungen ausgesetzt beschimpfung das
ansehen in der bevölkerung ist natürlich
auch äußerst gering und man wundert sich
dass es überhaupt noch junge menschen
gibt die sich diesen beruf aussetzen und
wenn er dann womöglich auch noch
bestückt wird und dann richtet wieder
eine klientel und dann kann es sein und
womöglich ich will jetzt keine nein
keine lanze brechen das ist natürlich
schrecklich was er gesagt hat aber dann
hatte die distanz zu dem einst trotz
dieser familie einfach verloren und hat
sich hinreißen lassen es ist auch
menschlich auch
polizeibeamte sind menschen und als auch
einen querschnitt der gesellschaft hier
haben sie überall es gibt weiße graue
und auch schwarze schafe
also uns aber trotzdem noch mal ganz
klar zu sagen du hast es selbst am
eingang dieses gesprächs gesagt ein ganz
klarer rassismus skandal hier der
natürlich nicht toleriert werden kann
vielen dank matthias becker
[Musik]